[Musique]
notre ca ce soir jean martin aussant
jean luc landry messieurs bonsoir
bonsoir au choix françois legault donc à
la coop 26 avec toute une délégation
avec des objectifs économiques une
mission à saveur économique il dit qu'il
est là pour faire valoir les intérêts du
québec pour positionner le québec comme
étant un leader mondial dans la lutte
contre les changements climatiques jean
martin d'abord est ce que c'est une
bonne vision des moyens à prendre pour
lutter contre les changements
climatiques que cette vision qui est
exprimé par le premier ministre ben je
trouve que oui parce que quelque part
s'est aligné avec les intérêts de la
lutte contre les changements climatiques
parce que le québec a tout ce qu'il faut
pour être un leader mondial dans ces
nouvelles technologies lors les
nouvelles énergies propres et tous les
sommets à mon avis sont bons pour faire
valoir les avantages du québec parce que
pendant des décennies nous on a enrichi
les pays qui exportait du pétrole si
maintenant c'est notre tour d'exporter
des énergies propres pour que la planète
entier en bénéficient mais tant mieux je
pense que c'est pertinent que ce soit le
cas ok jean-luc là dessus
deux choses d'abord que je trouve le
gouvernement utilise trop souvent leader
mondial on est un petit pays je surfais
que le président de la chaîne n'a aucune
idée où est ce que le québec et par
conséquent on se prétend leader mondial
c'est tout à fait ça fait comme si vous
étiez au baseball mais vous allez là
pour faire un run à chaque fois en
général quand vous choisi par laurent
gbagbo alors on devrait se servir de nos
choses le mieux possible mais arrêtez de
sites prétendent qu'on hérite d'un bon
dia deuxièmement le québec qui porte le
meilleur là dedans depuis une dizaine
d'années on a une réduction des gaz à
effet de serre au québec mais on n'a pas
de leçon à donner à personne sur ce
sujet
c'est vrai que jean martin on est dans
l'hyperbole de temps en temps on est
numéro un on est les meilleurs on est
leaders mondiaux ce que j'ai entendu
qu'à raison de dire faudrait peut-être
se calmer un peu l'hyperbole savez tout
ce qui est excessif est insignifiant
comme disait talleyrand je suis d'accord
avec ça sauf qu'on a tout ce qu'il faut
pour devenir le leader mondial surtout
sur ce plan là mais si on arrêtait
d'investir nos dollars dans l'est dans
le pétrole de l'ouest entre autres c'est
notre débat un bref on a tout ce qu'il
faut pour être un leader mondial
incontesté l'aude à la norvège est un
petit pays qui s'est enrichi avec les
énergies fossiles on est un petit pays
sont aussi très bien s'enrichir avec les
énergies propres aujourd'hui jean martin
s'il vous plaît dites moi où on est où
on assez grand avantage on a tout le
long des berges élixir et on a le
solaire la biomasse le studio lien on
n'a pas trop l'air tout
comme un pays nordique d'un grand
deuxièmement quand général si vous
voulez me lancer dans les batteries sa
vie d'où viennent les batteries ils
viennent de chine tout tout ce qu'on
fait et lyon électrique accéder à toutes
ces nouvelles machines et on n'a même
pas les produits qui sont les produits
essentiels pour faire des batteries bon
elle est aussi benjamin button et mûri
dans tout pays vit pour un petit pain
mais moi je pense quelques baigneurs
c'est pas ça mais ce grand leader se
prétendent ce qu'on y passer trop
dangereux s'ils sont bons points moi je
pense qu'on les
met le québec se targue d'avoir un
excellent bilan un bon bilan mais je
pense qu'il faut pas oublier non plus
qu'on a quand même délocalisé une bonne
partie de notre production depuis 25 ans
nos émissions industrielles sont
ailleurs maintenant on a délocalisé
notre pollution aussi jean martin donc
en quelque chose jusqu'à quel point on
peut se dire ah ben on n'est pas pire
quand même on a baissé de 25% nos
émissions industrielles on est à peu
près les meilleurs en amérique du nord
si on a délocalisé une partie de notre
pollution la mondialisation a mené ça
c'est vrai puis je pense que c'est un
signe que justement les analyses
simplement économiques ne sont plus
valables parce que si on se disait que
ça coûtait moins cher de faire produire
à l'extérieur et 2
réimporter sans suite on excluait les
impacts sociaux et environnementaux
parce que quand on voit maintenant la
pollution que ça amène et le coût que ça
coûtera où le coût que cela impliquera
de corriger ça mais si le prix des
produits qu'on faisait produire
l'extérieur inclus et où est internalisé
les effets sociaux ou environnementaux
le prix serait de loin gonflé et donc ce
qu'on voit c'est qu'une analyse une
analyse simplement économique ça
explique trop d'externalités et le prix
et paul l'unique facteur qui vous
regardez dans ces cas là
vous avez dit que on est on a baissé de
25% sûr c'est qu'en fait le calcul je
parle des sur la bridge de carbone genou
n'ont pas du tout je parle de des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre de
1990 à 2000 18 dans le secteur des
industries mais dans le secteur du
transport n'augmenter de 33% mon a
baissé de 24% pour l'industrie la
désindustrialisation de notre économie à
faire en sorte qu'on a baissé
alors l'industrie a fait le travail mais
le globalement on n'a pas honoré aux
bienfaits dans le sens que 1 pour ce qui
du du transport qui est le public
québécois on n'a pas avancé beaucoup en
fait ça augmenter ok je vous entendre
sur marcel boyer ce matin dans la presse
plus
fellow du cirano économistes bien connu
réputé au québec marcel boyer qui dit
que les états du monde
en fait que toutes ces conférences qu'on
fait comme celle de glace course un
échec en partant tant et aussi longtemps
que les états du monde ne se seront pas
vraiment entendus pour appliquer une
tarification du carbone vous en
pensez-quoi jean-luc
100% d'accord
ce meeting lol ça redonne sur la table
un repli de carbone qui augmente dans
les prochains quinze ans que tout le
monde peut prévoir et là les gens
s'entendent pour le faire ce qu'on a eu
c'est un meeting de belles promesses
comme d'habitude alors moi je suis rendu
comme je suis très bien greater une
balle de là dessus la selle sont les
premières ces avis sont le fédéral ceci
dit le gouvernement fédéral afin de
promesses qui est extrêmement
significative c'est d'augmenter le prix
du carbone jusqu'à 170 dollars la tonne
en 2030 ceux-là c'est énorme mais mais
globalement les autres comme ça qu'une
promesse le de réduire en 2050 c'est
comme si vous aviez dit
jean luc landry et greta thunder
d'accord voici ce que great attenberg
10h05 au
profit de celle ci
[Applaudissements]
alors vous jean martin ça vous fait
plaisir jean luc mais jean martin quand
vous entendez ça est-ce que glasgow
c'est du bla bla bla mais pour être
chérir ce que jean-luc disait des
promesses vides ça sert à rien mais j'ai
bien aimé le passage leur ticket
monsieur boyer qui d'ailleurs était mon
directeur de maîtrise je le salue j'ai
bien aimé le passage où il réussit jean
claude juncker qui avait dit que les
élus savent très bien ce qu'il faut
faire mais savent pas comment être réélu
s'il le font donc il faut simplement
mettre les intérêts collectifs avant
l'intérêt individuel ou de réélection
puis là dessus je voudrais venait
anecdote dans mon cas particulier à moi
quand j'ai été élu en 2008 j'avais dans
mon compte est la seule centrale
nucléaire au québec qui est gentil et
quand je me suis rendu compte que ça
coûterait 7 milliards pour faire la
réflexion tout ça pour à peu près 700
emplois donc 10 millions de dollars par
emploi mais j'ai milité pour faire
fermer la centrale dans mon propre
compte et puis ça me coûtait en partie
mon siège l'élection d'après pcistes à
refaire je le referai pas ce qu'une et
les galeries élections il faut post 7
milliards de fonds publics puis je pars
je pense que de plus en plus les
policiers vont penser à l'intérêt
collectif avant les leurs il le faut en
tout cas ok il nous reste juste une
minute à peu près là je vais vous
demander trop de secondes de réponse
chacun sur le référendum les habitants
du maine qui se prononce sur ce projet
de ligne électrique new england clean
energy connect qui va permettre à
hydro-québec d'amener son électricité
jusqu au massachusetts jean luc est ce
que vous trouvez que et les américains
et hydro québec ont fait tout ce qu'il
fallait où là on est soumis un
référendum qui pourrait faire échouer ce
projet là
je pense qu on y suit un programme qui
va le faire échouer ça c'est syndrome
pas dans ma cour et il ya de bonnes
chances que étant donné que ça s'adresse
pas directement aux gens du marine ils
voudront pas collaborer mais ils sont
pas différents des autres où je suis et
dry concombre au québec mais là descend
d'une ligne dans les laurentides tout le
monde se posait sa vie régulière tout à
fait jean martin c'est monstrueux c'est
rare qu'on voit référendum où le oui
signifie un rejet et le nom signifie
l'acceptation je trouve que la question
était alambiquées pour que le nombre à
apporter je pense que c'est mal parti
pour pour cette étape du projet si on
dit non au projet est le projet c'est
non c'est ça non il est pas mal
embûches pour la continuation du projet
ok on va reparler demain de toute façon
parce qu'on aura probablement des
résultats merci à vous deux amandine
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit